the true death toll from Kovac 19 is
revealed in the latest official figures
from the office for national statistics
they've looked at the average number of
people who would be expected to die for
the time of year in England and Wales
and they added in the death
registrations for 2020 in all there have
been more than 46,000 extra death
between the start of the epidemic in
March and the beginning of May these
excess deaths as they're called include
not just those with Kovach 19 recorded
on their death certificate but also
deaths attributed to other causes and
the stats show there were 13,000 extra
non-coated 19 deaths over this period of
these the biggest increase over the
long-term average was in deaths
attributed to dementia up 52 percent
it's likely that these were care home
residents whose lives were cut short by
the virus even if that wasn't reflected
on their death certificate and has also
been a big increase in death from causes
such as asthma and diabetes in mid April
they spiked at 197 percent and 161
percent above average and they were
outside hospital so it's likely to
reflect a reluctance to seek medical
attention during the epidemic but a
second report by the ons shows the
epidemic is tailing off 53,000 people in
England had the virus in their latest
household survey that's hard down from
133,000 last week in fact the ONS says
there is a steady fall now more than
0.4% of the population were infected at
the end of April by the end of May it
was just 0.1% although there are still
five and a half thousand people a day
catching the virus the latest estimate
of the our number is 0.7 to 0.9 below
the key threshold of 1 indicating that
the spread of the virus is slowing but
these stats predate the easing of the
lockdown
earlier this week we'll see in the
coming days whether more social contact
has increased spread of the virus